[Music]
only for airline tickets you own your
own Airline don't you do you still own
your own Airline oh they haven't taken
that away from you yet huh no good
[Applause]
man
wait a minute we gotta get a word no how
did you do that I don't know I have no
idea
who says there's not luck in football
you are the
Florida one time everybody
's Rob
everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's February 13 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals share subscribe tap
notification bells and if you want to
join us for the post game show which
people are really digging join us at
reubenreport.locals.com I thought that
that was sort of the appropriate cold
open for today's show because yesterday
was the big Super Bowl which actually
was quite a game the ending was a little
marred with that uh that illegal defense
called the pass interference call but
all good congratulations to the Fine
people of Kansas City and the Chiefs and
all that good stuff
um and of course what I want to talk
about today is if you were watching the
commercials and for many people I'd say
for probably half the country or half
half the people watching that freaking
thing uh they are watching basically for
the commercials one of the things that I
really realized and it probably doesn't
come as any great surprise to you guys
is that I am really just so not
interested in what the mainstream
culture pushes out it feels so
homogenized and boring and everything is
a member Barry you know the South Park
member Barry meme like that's what it is
everything is like we have to remember
back now it was very heavy on 80s and
90s references which I love all that
stuff but it's like going to the well
one too many times with washed up actors
and old things we used to care of care
for and about and it just doesn't quite
work anymore and and just all the Pomp
and Circumstance the black national
anthem which was completely ridiculous
and if you saw the at the at the end
zones they had the digi I think it was
digitally placed do you know if it was
digitally placed where it was on the
field it's self the end racism in the
end zone so I guess we knocked out
racism which was very exciting so that
was good at least by doing that uh and
then of course this morning all the all
the Articles across mainstream media it
was the blackest Super Bowl ever we had
two black quarterbacks and racism in the
end zone Brianna's black uh black this
but like nobody cares nobody cares was
the game good Diana had a sing Lady
anyway
the way I wanted to start the show today
was a little bit about that one
particular commercial that I sense if
you watch this show it got you thinking
too uh it was that Disney
commercial the Hundred Years of Disney
which was really a fascinating
commercial and I think it is deeply
deeply connected the way that they put
this PR statement out there this
commercial very different from all of
their activities that we've been
covering here for well over a year so
we're going to compare those two things
and kind of show you how that's
connected to what's going on culturally
and politically at the moment and I
think I think there were a couple other
hints yesterday you can sort of see what
the new cultural and political Alliance
is going to look like I think this thing
is beginning to form some kind of shape
and I think that's actually quite good
for whatever's going to happen in 2024.
anyway by the way one other thing that
cold open there apparently when Donald
Trump threw that football through that
little hole there it won somebody a
million bucks that was back in 1992
before he was a white supremacist I
guess uh all right let's talk about
moink box real quick and then we'll get
to it did you guys know that 60 of U.S
pork production comes from one company
owned by the Chinese and their Hogs are
given something called ractopamine which
is banned in 160 countries including
China yet you find it in your grocery
aisle every day there's a better way
guys I want to tell you about moink
that's moo plus oink moink delivers
grass-fed and grass-finish beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the point difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farm stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel any time there's
nothing better than cooking their meats
on my green egg on a Friday evening
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and ring doorbell founder Jamie
simenov jumped at the chance to invest
in moike plus they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got moaned
keep American farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time Moi and
kbox.com
rubenmoinkbox.com Reuben and now back to
me all right so let's get to it now you
may remember we played one of these
clips yesterday there's a whole slew of
Disney Plus shows that are out right now
and as you guys know the people behind
the scenes the executive producers the
writers the directors all of these
people they are woke Beyond woke they
are double woke they are quadruple woke
eight times woke and they have made it
their goal to put their political
ideology into children's programming
okay now for a long time and probably
perhaps forever artists at some level
put some sort of political or cultural
message in a painting or in music or in
there the way they act whatever it might
be that in and of of itself is actually
okay that's the point of good art
because it says something that's beyond
just looking at the picture right that's
the actual point of art but what these
people are doing are putting a political
ideology into messaging for young
children to change the way they think
and that is very different than why an
artist might create art in its purest
sense so before we show you the Disney
100 year anniversary commercial that
they showed during the Super Bowl
yesterday this is the thing that they
wanted everybody to see on the biggest
TV day of the year I want to show you
one more clip of the new Disney Plus
show Proud family which is on right now
I don't have Disney plus I canceled it
you have Disney plus no Disney plus no
Disney Plus in this room okay but this
is proud family on Disney plus enjoy
how do you understand love don't you no
no I do not understand anything about
white fragility white virginity what's
that supposed to mean you know what it
means you're doing it right now you're
doing what being defensive about race
Robert D'Angelo wrote a whole book about
it read it yet again
same um
cover and everything
[Music]
at the diary he said his people would
never own slaves
they just dismissed me like that white
fertility okay so you must understand
this is not entertainment for children
this is pure propagandic
um disinformation intentional confusion
of children why would any child let's
say a six-year-old a seven-year-old
eight-year-old is watching that how
about entertaining them for the sake of
entertainment
maybe you could teach them something but
to teach them the ideas of white
fragility which is basically the the
the Genesis the beginning of all of what
is so wrong with this woke mind disease
and that parents don't even think about
it they just plop that kid down in front
of that TV and by the way I get the
inclination for this with a
six-month-old and a four-month-old one
of the few things when they're both kind
of going nuts at the same time and
they're really well behaved but I've had
a couple moments where I've sat them in
front of the TV with me we put on we put
on nature shows right we just watch
frogs jumping around and some fish and a
lion and an elephant they seem to be big
on elephants but I get the inclination
to just put your kid down in front of
the TV and then you think oh Disney I
have some recollection of Disney being
decent they're not gonna really try to
brainwash my child are they no it's
Disney of old
well speaking of Disney of old so now
let's compare what you just saw of what
their current programming is and you all
know we showed you the interviews and
those leaked Zoom videos of the the
activists at the company telling you
they are putting their secret agenda
into the programming now look how
different that is compared to Disney's
100th anniversary commercial that they
played for the nation to see during the
Super Bowl
open your
[Music]
app think of the one place you've always
wanted to see
[Music]
swear our magic comes from
they say if you dream a thing more than
once please please
it's sure to come true
everything you see
exists together in the great circle of
life
there are stories about what happened
it's true
in every job that must be done there is
an element of fun I told you she was
tricky
life is full of possibilities what do
you want to be remembered for
world is in our hands and we gotta do
something with it
I just want to say a word of thanks to
all the artists the workers
and all of you
the Young
foreign
you helped make this dream come true
[Music]
isn't that interesting guys when they
want to put the money to make the
commercial to put it on the most watched
television thing of the year there's
none of the wokeness there's no
neo-racism we don't have boy princesses
there's no black woman lecturing a white
guy about what he did wrong or what his
ancestors did wrong they went straight
up to the heart of why we all once loved
Disney for great characters and stories
and Imagination
without getting too critical of it you
know my feelings about what they've done
to Star Wars and everything else then
they bought all of these properties and
I think it is a problem when one giant
corporation owns So Many of a culture's
dream say Star Wars all of Marvel all
the cartoons etc etc but let's just put
that aside for the purpose of this why
is it that they felt they should pour
that money into promoting that why if
they are so proud of the woke
programming that they're putting out
here and that Buzz Lightyear what
happened he slept with the dude or
whatever happened in that last movie and
the other thing and just these people
that are pushing neo-races my children
why wasn't any of that in there now I'm
gonna guess actually that Bob Iger who
is the once and current uh CEO of Disney
that he has a headache on his hands this
morning over there at Disney because I'm
guessing a whole bunch of his woke
employees some of whom we showed you in
those leaked Zoom videos they got to be
pretty pissed today hey how come you
just went and showed all that old stuff
that was probably written by a bunch of
white supremacists and didn't have
enough of people like us and blah blah
blah blah blah and now he's got his
diversity equity and inclusion group
over there his HR Group that's probably
going to be attacking him now he's gone
out of his way to clean up some of that
we showed you a couple weeks ago a video
of him being interviewed saying hey
we're going to try to get away from some
of the political stuff and just
entertain people but again why would he
say that why would Disney go out of
their way to spend an awful lot of money
to ignore the woke stuff and get you to
think that Disney is Disney of old well
there might be a reason for it because
there is this guy here in the Free State
of Florida who was not happy about any
of this nonsense and he said no more
Disney we're taking away your tax breaks
we're taking away some of your
self-governing privileges we're taking
away a whole bunch more from the way
you're running Orlando and running so
many people's lives because you're
propagandizing to children that guy's
name is Ron DeSantis and uh yeah he's
beaten Disney and well listen to the
governor himself
Disney's going to pay its debt and I
think if you remember when we did the
initial special session where we set the
Sunset date and we knew we'd have to
deal with this I always said that
they're going to come in and we're going
to we're going to figure out the best
way to do it uh so so what I said really
for the last six nine months is
Disney is no longer going to have
self-government they're not going to
have their own government Disney is
going to pay its fair share of taxes and
Disney's going to honor the debt and
that's exactly what this proposed piece
of legislation will do if you remember
when we first went down this road last
spring a lot of folks in the media were
saying that oh my gosh Disney's actually
going to pay less taxes and Floridians
are going to pay more taxes they were
saying that and I'm like you've got to
be kidding me well this puts that to bed
and so those debts will be honored and
those will be paid now this is obviously
now going to be controlled by the state
of Florida which is no longer
self-governing for them so there's a new
sheriff in town and that's just the way
it's going to be
foreign
[Applause]
maybe we'll do some more Florida
resident discount who knows all right so
you see what's going on here this is why
I started the show by saying that what
is happening right now is we are seeing
the cultural and political Alliance come
together that I think can get us out of
this stuff right it's not nothing that
Disney put this commercial up it's
because they're back on their heels
because they're losing the tax breaks
and the self-governance and I think they
had an airport there that's now not
going to be fully their airport and a
whole bunch of other stuff but the point
is DeSantis came in as a political
leader picked a fight that everyone said
he was going to lose you can look at all
of the articles on this thing you can't
beat Disney suddenly the lefties who
were supposed to be against giant
corporations they were really into giant
corporations and Biden was getting up
there going and run the services
attacking Mickey Mouse and that's also
what Gavin Newsom said and it's like no
he's not attacking Mickey Mouse he's
attacking the corporatist people behind
Mickey Mouse who have been completely
and wholly infected by wokism who are
trying to destroy families and the
brains of children and all sorts of
other things Disney also Disney plus
lost
2.4 million subscribers last year I'm
one of those subscribers 2.4 million so
they're doing this commercial because
DeSantis chose as a political leader to
get involved in the culture Awards and
when you start doing that and you start
pushing back their nonsense crumbles
rather quickly now one of the advantages
that they have is they have the entire
mainstream media so there were a bunch
of clips from The View on Friday I have
to show you them it's gonna it's several
it's a couple Clips here just completely
Insanity going on at the view and I
would love to can you give me the name
of the executive producer of The View I
want to shout this guy out because I
would love to sit down with this guy I
think his name's Brian something I would
love to have this guy on uh because he
is now putting on I think probably the
most dangerous show on television
because it is brainwashing so many women
let's say of a certain age his name is
Brian tetta Brian teda you are the EP of
the view I would love to sit down with
you we can do it live no notes let's
talk it out the the Stark difference
between the propaganda that you put out
every day and what I try to clean up up
here every day so on Friday the view was
going after Des sadness right and why
are they going after DeSantis well
DeSantis just showed you something he
showed if you fight giant corporations
and do the right thing the people will
back you you'll win by 20 points and
then you can beat the corporations the
other thing of course to say this is
doing is getting wokism out of schools
we are not going to teach AP
African-American studies to high
schoolers who are going to get college
credit for it while also learning about
gender queer Theory okay obviously these
things are not connected and this is too
uh indoctrinate not educate so they
tried to discuss this on The View and
just listen to the Litany of nonsense
and they all learned about black history
they all learned it so I want to know
how do you know that because I know that
they knew more than there was slaves
they knew the things that some black
folks did yeah
so I know they learned that that's what
they're trying to suppress so this is
what this is what I'm trying to figure
out what did you learn that scared you
so badly that you are trying to
remove this
from schools now I want to answer your
question what it's about yeah what it's
about is Fanning the Flames of anger
grievances distress frustration hours no
in the base it's manufacturing culture
listen the base needs to understand
everybody's pissed about something you
know the last three or four years have
not been great for everybody and
possibly for anybody how dare you use
that your anger
to pretend an entire section of the
United States doesn't exist
let me get you to the part that's really
incredible in just a second but we
really need a phrase for Whoopi or maybe
Whoopi should be we should use it in a
different way as just instead of her
name like to Whoopi is to just bloviate
on a bunch of nonsense you have no idea
about they are not trying to remove the
history of slavery or of civil rights
from high school or junior high school
or anywhere else in Florida they are
specifically going after one AP course
which would be taught in high school to
give college credit to kids where part
of the course itself will teach critical
race Theory we'll get to that in a
second part of it will teach about the
importance of reparations that's
teaching policy future policy to kids
that's not right and also gender queer
Theory did Harriet Tubman go down on a
couple chicks while she was getting them
through the Underground Railroad there's
a sentence that's never been said before
but it continues now you also have to
remember as you watch this clip so
Whoopi Whoopi is just Whoopi she has no
idea what she's saying but she says it
with a lot of emotion and that is really
good for for leftists they love emotion
over anything that has to do with
reality then Anna Navarro there and Anna
used to be a sane Republican she worked
for I believe she was Marco Rubio right
here in Florida she was Marco Rubio's
campaign manager and now she is just
another crazy person that somehow she's
telling you the whole base of her former
party or I think she still pretends to
be a republican uh is all a bunch of
racist yet somehow they were supporting
Marco Rubio I'm pretty sure he's not
white uh and everything else and then
here we go here's Alyssa Farah this is
she's really you know Sunny hosting you
know my feelings on her like she's just
like a genuine racist and awful just
like they're just so bad okay fine Al
Alyssa Farah though Alyssa Farah Griffin
her name is
she used to work for Mitt Romney she is
the token conservative on this panel and
what she doesn't seem to understand is
for the I don't know how many they
probably give her about three million
dollars a year to be on to host that
show something like that a couple years
so you're gonna make some serious cash
on that thing what she doesn't realize
is no matter how much she sells her soul
joy and whoopee and Anna the rest of
them they will still sell her out one
day they will still destroy her this
will not end well these people will not
be her friends everyone will turn
against her and yes she'll have a little
cash and I hope it's worth it for her
but now it's where it starts getting
crazy and you can see how I'm connecting
this to culture Disney politics DeSantis
and media take a look this is really
important what Rhonda fantas did with
Banning AP black history that is going
way further than what many members of my
party have have raised concerns with so
there's a lot of parents who get
concerned with elements of critical race
Theory getting listen I'm going to say
this one more time elements of critical
race Theory are not taught to
five-year-olds it's not taught to
eight-year-olds not taught to 10 year
olds but the 10 year olds learn listen
you know what if you're scared of
American History I
I don't get it but I do think it's an
important distinction because what he's
doing is so absurd and it's going so far
you're literally talking about erasing
history not bringing in the theories and
the theoreticals and the more college
level stuff this is straight up saying
we're not going to learn about slavery
we're not going to learn about this
that's also happening in Texas as well I
just want to like kind of separate those
two not that both don't deserve to be
discussed but that's going dangerously
far I don't know that Sarah or anyone I
think Texas
at me yeah sorry I don't think Arkansas
is trying to do quite that yet okay
first off let me just talk to you Alyssa
we're going to clip this and put it on
Twitter and I'm going to tag Alyssa
Alyssa by the way shuts off all her
mentions because nobody likes her and uh
she doesn't want to read that and I get
why they don't like her because she's a
liar she we you know we say the word
grifter a lot or sellout I can't imagine
at this point someone that's doing it at
a higher level than her like maybe her
former boss Mitt Romney like something
like that but everything she said there
was a lie they are not Banning talk
about slavery they are not Banning talk
about civil rights whoopee once again
just whoopied the whole thing meaning
she just completely made things up AP
courses which is that's what this is
about are not taught to five-year-olds
or six-year-olds or eight-year-olds
they're still going to learn about all
of those things I'd get an honest
assessment of History they're going to
get educated about history instead of
indoctrinated about history but this
Pharaoh woman she's either a complete
idiot or a grifter there's no way
there's no in between there and and I
suspect she's not a complete idiot so
what she is doing is saying I will take
a certain amount of money to sit at this
table to lie AI about the people that
are defending the ideals that me as a
supposed conservative are is are
supposed to believe in that's exactly
what she is doing she is ridiculous and
a buffoon this has nothing to do with
racism you tell me what gender queer
theory has to do with an honest
assessment of civil rights absolutely
nothing
Ben Shapiro has an interesting line on
this that I thought was apropos put this
tweet up uh he's talking about this
lizzo flute controversy now you may
remember a couple weeks ago lizzo who is
this tremendously giant woman who I
guess is a singer she's a singer or yeah
she's a singer okay and she she's huge
this woman and she loves being huge so
I'm not even making fun of her she is a
giant tremendous huge woman she wears
skimpy little bikinis she plays the
flute
anyway here's what Ben said about it and
you'll see how I'm connecting these
things this lizzo flute controversy is a
perfect example of what I have termed
face tattoo phenomenon the phenomenon
whereby someone does something
deliberately controversial in an attempt
to draw attention and then acts offended
when you notice this is exactly what
these people have been doing they get in
your face and say we are going to teach
African-American history we are going to
combine it
there's no problem in and of itself with
that we are going to combine that with
genderqueer Theory this is going to be
an extension of critical race Theory and
it's going to yes whoopee even though AP
courses aren't taught to five year olds
all of this stuff is going to leak down
into every age that every child is at at
school and it will still be pushed by
Disney see the videos that we just
showed you a moment ago and every
cultural thing will infect them and
every educational institution will
infect them and all of the stuff so but
this is exactly what they do and this is
what Ben is referring to because then
when you push back they get the reaction
that they want because then they are the
victim and they love that so that is why
they hate DeSantis what DeSantis is
doing all he is doing he's doing two
things I would say he's saying stop
enough is enough
that's the first thing and that's the
most important thing because we're
always on this slow descent to woke hell
and we keep going and going and going
and we have been waiting for a couple
people you know picture it it's it's a
train right it's a train going down a
track you got the Ravine over there and
you're just going and going and going
and you're you know the ravine's coming
but and every now and again so slow down
speed bump ahead but you need somebody
to say stop you are going to go off into
the Ravine this will not end well for
any of you you are going to undo
everything that is great about this
country I get it they don't think this
stuff is that great for some reason they
never leave DeSantis is saying stop
that's number one okay so he's getting
the train to stop and then what's he
doing then he's pulling the curtain back
and he's saying guys explain to me how
genderqueer theory has something to do
with African-American studies explain to
me why Disney a giant Corporation
deserves all of these extra benefits and
can basically be running its own country
within our state and by doing that by
just exposing the nonsense he has the
Liars the frauds the grifters he has
them all freaking out to the point that
someone like Alyssa Farah Griffin
is up there on The View taking money to
lie about the Republicans and
conservatives Whoopi is just brain dead
she and and so is Joy they they are lost
and confused they will never turn around
right this is where I can make a
complete distinction between say a
whoopee and a joy they are all in on the
nonsense versus someone like Bill Maher
who still is getting half of it right he
hasn't gotten there on the election part
of it but he's getting a whole bunch
right still
these people are encouraging the lunacy
and now you have these fraud people on
the right encouraging it as well and
that is why they hate santis and here's
DeSantis himself laying out why this
course is not going to be taught here in
Florida what's one of the lessons about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so when you look
to see they have stuff about
intersectionality abolishing prisons
that's a political agenda and so we're
on that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards
right
I don't think that queer theory has
anything to do with African-American
studies I was thinking about it while we
were playing that clip uh you remember
in Revenge of the Nerds there was Larry
B Scott and he was the gay guy in the
fraternity with the javelin so unless
you're going to teach a course on him
which I do think would be completely
legitimate as a child of the 80s then
this is all complete nonsense but let's
link this further to what's going on
politically and culturally right now uh
one of the fights that's happening is a
fight that obviously has been looming
this thing is coming right now it's a
one-way fight and the media is loving
every freaking second of it and of
course what I'm talking about is the uh
DeSantis Trump fight now it seems to be
a one-way fight as I said because Trump
is the one going on the attack DeSantis
is kind of just standing there
continuing to govern let me give you the
caveats I voted for Trump I want to
interview him again I like him I like
his children however his behavior over
the last couple weeks has been really
really bananas and I would say DeSantis
is basically giving a master class in
how to fight it off you know we've seen
Trump do a lot of crazy things over the
years A lot of them I think were
absolutely necessary to break through
the so a lot of the law corrupt
a lot of that stuff it was it was
necessary to to shake the system in a
way so we owe Trump to we owe him
because he doled out red pills to
everybody he got us to see again that
behind that curtain thing that I talked
about with the scientists a moment ago
Trump did that better than anybody
um but but we also saw him use tactics
you know Little Marco and he said Ted
Cruz's wife is ugly and like all of
these things and nobody's loyal to him
him but he throws all of his ex people
under the bus anyway he's going
overboard in his attacks on DeSantis
like unnecessarily overboard considering
that he backed DeSantis he claims that
he made the scientist he lives in the
state that DeSantis is governing right
now and DeSantis obviously even though
he has not announced and I have to tell
you I talked about it a lot with a
couple people this weekend let me just
cards on the table for real guys there
is a huge part of me that does not want
DeSantis to run and in some ways it's
even the bigger part of me than the part
that that thinks that we should turn
this whole country around meaning I live
in the state that is the most functional
competence date we have the best head
executive his work has just begun he's
continuing to do everything and we could
use four more years of him doing all of
these great things the real question is
do you send your best soldier out there
is a war there is a war Bruin
or a coming or it's The Barbarians are
at the gate do you send your best guy
out knowing that maybe the war can't be
what maybe the machine is that powerful
maybe Trump is willing to do things that
would be that evil and irreparably harm
him and all of those things so I think
there is a strong I really mean this
there is a strong strong argument for
DeSantis to stay right here and maybe as
a Floridian I just should not care that
much about the grander experiments at
this point I'm not saying that's fully
where I'm at but I think there is a
strong argument to be made on that but I
do for sure think that the Senate this
would be the best president and I
certainly think he is the biggest threat
to the system because he is Trump but
competent okay so putting just all of
that out there just put that in a little
bucket for a moment here's a couple
things that Trump has been doing uh and
you tell me if you if you if this feels
right to you if you think this is going
to work and just pointing out once again
we don't even know if DeSantis is going
to run and this is extremely early so it
seems like you're throwing the kitchen
sink out at this point here's uh here's
Trump on Truth social apparently some
random person dong Chang Lee uh found on
Truth social found this picture we're
told that apparently this is Ron
DeSantis at some point I don't know and
it says here is Ron de sanctimonious
worst nickname ever it's not sticking
grooming high school girls with alcohol
as a teacher okay first off it's not
clear if that's doctored or not secondly
um it could be non-alcoholic beer it
could be root beer we don't know what
the hell it is there's no none of these
girls have like it's even to me talking
about this in some ways I'm doing
Trump's dirty work here which I don't
like but the point is does anyone think
that that's really a rep a good
representation of the life that Ron
DeSantis is living and did did all of us
do crazy things in college and all of
that stuff but he's doing that kind of
thing and
and what oh so just put it up one more
time so what he what Trump added to it
was that's not Ron is it he would never
do such a thing I mean this is Donald
Trump grab him by the so it's like
is this the game you want to play man is
this the game you want to play so
DeSantis is wisely just playing this
thing real cool take a look
and I'd also just say this
I spend my time delivering results for
the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden that's how I spend my
time
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't spend my time trying to smear
other Republicans
yeah that's the right answer that's the
right I'm here to do a job and I'm doing
that job and I'm doing it better than
anybody and you back to me and you live
in my state and I don't think anyone
wants that crap one of the things that's
interesting and Trump has done a few of
these types of messages
I'm actually sort of sorry I even showed
it because it butterfly affects the
thing and it's just nonsense it's not
going anywhere okay fine
um but Trump if you're willing to take
out the guy who probably is the best guy
we've got then are you really America
First at that point that's the question
now interestingly I want to link this uh
to the guy I mentioned a moment ago Bill
Maher because on his show on Friday he
had a rather curious statement related
to what's going on with DeSantis and
Trump and I think he's sort of almost
accidentally made the argument that I've
been making for quite some time so
here's this from Fox News Real Time host
Bill Maher advised Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis to avoid the battle in the mud
with former president Donald Trump in
the 2024 election cycle as reports
indicate he will enter the race for the
White House I personally think that
would be a mistake for him Mar began a
panel discussion on Friday because he's
46 I think just let Trump Trump die
politically I mean or you know he's
older it could happen I'm not wishing it
but okay he'd still only be 50. Mark
continued if DeSantis got in against
Trump trump will do to him what he does
to everybody not just bloody him it'll
be a battle in the mud and all DeSantis
has to do is wait and he can be
president I normally would say the
opposite get in early before they pick
you apart but in this case with trump it
changes everything GOP pollster Kristen
soltis Anderson compared running against
Trump to running into a wood chipper but
disagreed with Mar that DeSantis should
wait it out since this is his moment you
don't get your moment all the time in
American politics soltis Anderson said
so what's interesting about this guys
and and again you know my feelings about
Mars so we don't have to you know we
don't have to rehash that it only is
worth listening to Mars opinion on this
if Marr honestly was going to vote for
DeSantis but I think sadly what Mar is
doing there and again I saw him last
week I like the guy AI so this is not a
personal attack Bill and I'm we're going
to play basketball at your house okay
this is not a personal attack but I am
fairly certain no matter whether it's
Trump or DeSantis you're going to vote
for the Democrat so really what you are
doing here is saying much more about
your intentions you want the weaker
candidate to run on the Republican side
and you view the weaker candidate As
Trump which actually is correct DeSantis
is the guy that can bring the moderates
DeSantis is the guy that can bring
the the disaffected Liberals and young
people like we know who's the new person
that's going to suddenly move to Trump
so Mars doing something it's like you're
advising DeSantis but I would only take
if I was this at this I would only take
advice from people that want to help me
not people that want to kneecap me and
that is the problem with what Bill
Maher's line of thinking there is
although as you guys know when I did
Bill Maher's podcast I got him to admit
he would move to Florida if California
ever came crashing down again when it
comes to lockdowns and mandates and all
of that stuff
um but I think you see it Bill Maher
again this is a guy that a week before
the election was saying if you if you
you know for all the stuff he gets right
on wokeness and free speech and all that
stuff he basically two three days before
the midterms was saying if you want to
save democracy you got to vote for
Democrats so why would DeSantis or any
sane Republican take uh his advice I
just don't know but okay where does that
lead us well 2024 is it coming and
apparently because Joe Biden did not
fall off the stage the other day at the
State of the Union did not knock the
podium over and had his eyeball explode
everybody's saying he's going to run
again because yes that really makes
sense we should have 83 he'll be 83 year
old Joe Biden man cannot complete a
sentence there is zero chance they let
him hold a phone has no idea what he is
doing occasionally they can drug him
with something really special I'll have
what she's having so that he can get out
there and pretend that he's functional
apparently he's going to run again
here's Karin Jean-Pierre okay say the
union is over when are we going to hear
the the big speech the Biden Harris 2024
announcements as you know I am I am
limited and what I can say I can't talk
about politics I am covered by by the
hatchback but what I can say is repeat
what the president has said many times
is that he intends to run I'll leave it
there I just don't even know what to say
about it it's like we're watching such a
poorly written script but we're all
stuck in it like is that what we need
again and again think about how the
world is changing the speed with which
technology is changing us how everything
is so wildly different than when Joe
Biden got involved in politics 50 years
ago and he somehow never solved racism
and he never got anything close to world
peace or any of those things but he's
the best they got at this point I mean
what is going on and okay Karen John
Pierre all she does she has nothing she
can't comment about politics she can't
say anything honestly saki's gonna
Circle back listen to this little piece
of Wizardly wisdom from Corinne why is
why is the American Military shooting
something out of the sky over Canada
because it's part of uh NORAD there is a
the NORAD is part of like a part of uh
it's a it's a what you call a coalition
vaccinations exactly and so that's why
we were able to do that again we didn't
do it on our own we did it in in uh
clearly in in in step with the Canadia
Canadia we did it with Canadia people
she's an idiot I mean she has no idea
what she's saying she moves her she's
doing this a lot because she's trying to
put words together because what I always
say to her she's just picking words and
she grabs words from thin air and she
puts them into a sentence she could not
tell you what NORAD is he had to kind of
walk her there
and Canadia he's always at war with East
Asia you get it all right uh but why are
we left with these people why are we
left
with a president who's barely
functioning a press secretary who can't
say anything honestly members of the
media like at the televised mental
institution MSNBC who lie about
everything but also promote a certain
point of view sometimes outwardly
sometimes very subtly why are we left
with them because the machine itself
incentivizes it and why does it
incentivize it because if you give the
machine whatever it wants meaning if you
give it more attention and more tax
dollars and more money and power over
people's lives that's what the machine
wants I don't know exactly what the
machine is it's like it's like asking
somebody what is the meaning of life in
the most and give me it in one sentence
so I don't know what the machine is is
it part of all of us that allows this to
happen is it is it Bill Gates in a group
of shadowy people is it some
amalgamation of like a lot of different
things probably but but if you were on
the side of always taking more money
if you are on the side of always forcing
people to inject themselves with things
or locking down if you're on the side of
big government and big Tech then you
will be incentivized the guy like
Stephen Colbert if you give the machine
What It Wants Jimmy Kim will give the
machine what it wants uh the other one
uh Jimmy who's the other one not Jimmy
Fallon yeah Jimmy Fallon you'll do your
stupid covid dance because you're not a
comedian you're just this little tool
who gives the machine what it wants and
you do it for an awful lot of money
right I don't think everything is boiled
down to money always but there's a
certain set of people that it does
Alyssa Griffin pharah Farah Griffin
whatever the hell her name is it's like
lady you have sold out every one of your
ideas whatever one of the things that
you purported to believe in so that you
can have money and fame and
congratulations you got it it's going to
destroy you sorry can't help you but
there we go so the machine incentivizes
it and that brings us to another thing
that's going on right now which is that
we are finding out not only through the
Twitter files but through some
Congressional hearings lately and we
showed you a couple Clips last week Jim
Jordan doing a bang-up job at those
hearings Lauren bobert doing a bang-up
job at those hearings going after
Twitter Executives as I said to you guys
they're going to have to go after FBI
agents as well like if we're going to do
anything about any of this somebody's
going to have to pay the price otherwise
otherwise the rest of us the same middle
the rest of the people that are watching
the show are just going to tune out of
the show because none of it will make
sense anymore oh we just have hearings
and nothing ever happens anyway one of
the people that has been fighting a lot
of this stuff
guess what guys she was a Democrat Tulsi
gabbard yeah she ran for president as a
Democrat and what did the Democrat Party
do it tried to destroy her what did
media do it tried to paint her as a
Syrian Ally or an ally of Assad in Syria
and anti-American she's a member of our
military a current member of our
military still to this day anyway she
testified uh in Congress about how
government and big Tech are basically
silencing you to see and say unto the
guise of protecting us from so-called
misinformation or disinformation now of
course they appoint themselves as the
sole Authority and Voice of Truth of
information
backed by the most lethal force on Earth
with the power to Target anyone they
deem a threat
they alone are the ones self-designated
who get to decide what is true and what
is false what is information and what is
misinformation or disinformation they
say they're doing this for us
that they're doing this for our own good
to protect the people
but in reality the truth is they think
that we're too stupid to think for
ourselves too stupid to discern for
ourselves and to draw our own
conclusions
now the idea that we must just blindly
accept whatever the government or those
in power tell us is true goes against
the very essence of our Constitution and
Bill of Rights
which were created as a resounding
rejection of the reign of Kings churches
and authorities
they tell us we must blindly trust them
or face the consequences okay so I'm
pretty sure you guys are on board
everything she said right there really
just think for one moment how different
so much could be had the Democrats when
they all cashed in their chips and cut
their back door deals to let Biden be
president and they all got out of the
way Tulsi stuck around and did not cut a
deal she was the last Democrat still
going against Biden and then eventually
they kicked her to the side too but
imagine had they instead of cutting a
deal with Kamala whatever that match
made in hell is all about imagine if
they had cut a deal with Tulsi and said
Tulsi actually some of your populism
stuff some of your non-radicalism you're
a lefty you're a liberal for sure
abortion gun rights okay stuff like that
but you're not like totally on board our
radical agenda but we will bring you
into the fold here and maybe that would
help moderate us a little bit get some
of that sane Senator back say the old
school liberals would be more okay with
the Democrat Party but instead you had
Hillary Clinton literally uh calling her
a spy and Mitt Romney calling her
treasonous she actually talked about
that
more recently U.S senator Mitt Romney
accused me of treason
a crime that is punishable by death
under our laws
I challenged him to back this back this
serious allegation up
with evidence what was this based on
there was no response
no explanation no evidence and certainly
no apology
now these accusations
are often Shrugged off as well hey it's
politics
people say things about each other all
the time that may be easy for some of
you to say but
for somebody who wears a uniform this is
serious and it's serious not only to me
but to my fellow service members and
Veterans every one of us making a
decision at some point in our lives to
raise our right hand
prepared and volunteering to lay our
life down for this country I love what
she said right there because she's
connecting her political service to her
military service and when you as she
points out when you go into the military
you don't know if you're coming back
alive you don't know if you're coming
back maimed or wounded you don't know
what mission they're going to send you
out on and when you go up there as a
politician you know they're going to say
the worst things about you but really
think about it which that woman Chelsea
gabbard was running for president
Hillary Clinton literally said she was a
Russian asset and nobody called Hillary
out on it it was just oh oh that's what
Hillary said you're allowed to do that
and that's what tulsi's saying it's like
you can say these things in politics
Mitt Romney had no reason to believe
that Tulsi is treasonous Tulsi just
doesn't buy the uniparty stuff that you
believe in I mean Brahma you pretend
you're a republican but you're really a
Democrat obviously and it's kind of
funny because we can link that to the
girl that used to work for you Alyssa
Farah Griffin I mean this is these
people the machine loves Republicans who
are really Democrats right so if you are
a republican if you're a republican
quote unquote who will go on TV and
constantly bash and lie about your own
side they love you whether that's Mitt
Romney whether that's Liz Cheney and by
the way the woman that they flashed to
you probably recognized her while Tulsi
was speaking was congresswoman Harriet
Hageman who we've had on the show before
who replaced Liz Cheney a republican who
would only go on TV and be lauded and
applauded because you would attack
Republicans so this is how the machine
operates the machine operates by always
running cover for the Democrats bringing
on Republicans who will take out their
side and then hiding
Democrats when need be so over the last
I don't know it's got to be decade or so
uh fox has done interviews with uh the
various presidents whether it was Obama
whether it was Trump a Bill O'Reilly did
a bunch of them uh there were several
people several several interviewers that
interviewed the presidents during the
Super Bowl Joe Biden declined to be on
Fox news or to decline the fox interview
so it would have aired at halftime he
declined no they would have aired it
right before the game Sorry I think it
was before the game
um he declined to do it and now here is
Oliver Darcy at CNN and this guy Oliver
Darcy he replaced disgraced potato uh
what the hell is his name Brian stelter
God these people like why do I have to
know all these people's names remember
potato Brian stelter yeah he was the
host of reliable sources of course this
guy Darcy who's just a total tool too
you'll see him in a second he replaces
him at reliable sources and here he is
holding water running cover for Biden
because Biden might have had a bit of a
tough interview if he had actually sat
down with someone at Fox News president
this current president doesn't want to
do it maybe future presidents won't want
to do it yeah Jim I think this really
underscores the level of commitment
Biden has showed to icing out Fox as you
as you said he hasn't granted this
right-wing talk Channel any interview
since he's been president and you can
imagine why I mean if you watch this
channel it's very clear there's a
there's a strong animus toward him
toward his administration and at night
time you have extremists people like
Tucker Carlson who are going on on these
rants who are spreading misinformation
and conspiracy theories about uh things
from the vaccines to January 6 and so I
think for this President he has decided
you know he's not going to call out the
channel he's not going to go to war with
it in that way but he's not going to
give it any Credence by appearing on
my buddy Viva fry who we had on the show
what was it last Friday confession
through projection right everything they
say is true about them first off it's
Biden's commitment it's really his
commitment to the truth that's why he
won't go on Fox News and you know it's
not as if he's going to be asked hard
questions right they would have put
Brett Bear up there or something like
that he would have got a couple maybe
slightly maybe maybe slightly but they
also edit everything by it and says he's
never going to do a live interview again
remember when he almost had that
complete full-on mental breakdown when
he was doing that town hall with
Anderson Cooper and Anderson was
basically finishing his sentences the
entire time so he obviously would have
done they wouldn't have been taping it
live to tape at exactly you know 6 15
before the game this would have been
something that would have been taped and
edited they would have had agreements
before that when he starts talking about
Corn Pop and his hairy leg we're gonna
we're gonna edit that out et cetera et
cetera
um also he talked this idea that it's
Fox it's somehow Fox who are the
extremists and they're sharing the
misinformation information about
vaccines you guys you CNN clowns you
shared all of the misinformation about
vaccines and cheered on vaccines that
you had no idea whether they were going
to work or not turns out that they don't
work and you guys shared all the lies
about January 6 the Insurrection nobody
had plans nobody had guns it's so
bizarre so everything they say is the
reverse of the truth but you know what
happens you know what happens when you
have crappy garbage crappy garbage
coming out of CNN and MSNBC and NBC and
ABC and CBS and everything else people
start looking for something a little
more true and then it not just leaks
through the the news portion of this it
leaks through all of the entertainment
side of this thing which is why a couple
times in the last few weeks I've brought
up is the view considered an
entertainment show or a news show
but what this wokism does what this
allegiance to the uniparty does is
basically cause everything to be
fraudulent and alive so it ruins them
sort of journalistically their inability
to say anything true because they're
always trying to point you in One
Direction but it also ruins their
ability to create anything good that's
why we don't have good new music it's
why we don't have good new TV shows and
movies sometimes every now and again
something can skate through every now
and again but it's certainly why we
haven't had good comedy in a while we
really have not at least at the at least
at the television level I've no doubt
people are doing live things that are
good and when we were out on tour we're
getting lots of laughs okay but what
does it all cause well if you put out a
bunch of cookie cutter carbon copies of
themselves on late night TV you know who
becomes number one in late night a guy
by the name of Greg Gutfeld who has
three writers and I'm pretty sure one
other guy that works on the show I
predicted on the debut of the Gutfeld
evening show which I was on I said you
will be number one in late night I think
we said within six months he made it in
three months they aired a quick spot
during the Super Bowl I just wanted to
throw to that fell new king of late
night commercial ready to roll isn't
this great is this cultural
appropriation
action hello America that's a wrap
what sorry these ads are pricey
and that's like perfect of why Gutfeld
is who he is at this point and why the
show is working like whatever they paid
for that doesn't even matter it doesn't
even matter if you think it's funny or
not the point is he's doing something a
little different and people have had
enough of it so how do I link this again
to where we started at the beginning
this cultural and political Alliance
that is coming together it's starting to
take shape we can kind of see it well
this is interesting look who is sitting
in the same box at the Super Bowl
well you've got some Brilliant Minds in
that photo Rupert Murdoch Elizabeth
Murdoch Elon Musk
Rupert pays our checks too so that's
always good
but uh yeah everyone take it in Super
Bowl 50. well isn't that something
Rupert Murdoch owner of Fox sitting with
Elon something's starting to cook Elon
bought Twitter all of these pieces are
kind of presenting itself and now let me
just do a little pat on the back The
Spectator had a really nice piece uh
this weekend that I was included in and
I thought it was apropos of everything
we're talking about here's a little
quote from the piece for several decades
Rush Limbaugh used radio to present a
conservative analysis of current affairs
to millions of Americans today a new
generation of commenters has emerged
achieving with the New Media what rush
using radio uh Joe Rogan Ben Shapiro
Dave Rubin and Dennis Prager each have
acquired audiences of millions in
Britain assorted YouTubers have achieved
something similar but is there not a
danger that these New Media pundits are
speaking to an audience that already
agrees with them such is the fragmented
nature of the modern media Market there
is little Prospect of reaching Beyond
those that already subscribe to their
world view the way that Rush Limbaugh's
ubiquitous broadcast were able to how
can we reach Beyond those that already
agree with us guys that the reason I
left that part in there is because that
has been my mission all along my life
literally my life my day-to-day
operation over these past however many
years that you've known me has been an
example of not only moving
if you look at my bio and everything
else it's like that's a guy that should
live in Cali but moving to Florida and
sure having some differences with some
people and maybe somebody's not thrilled
with this or that about me but putting
together this new Coalition of people
right that's why I talk about the
Libertarians and the ex-libs and the
religious conservatives and the new
school conservatives and all of these
things to put them together because that
is the tapestry of America and that is
why I love when I look in the comments
section and see that some of you
disagree with me on this or that or I
don't sit here and pretend to tell you
that I and I alone know the truth right
I leave some things with unanswered
questions so that you guys can think
about it too and then we can all kind of
play it out together and figure out
what's what so I would never want to be
in that in that sense of an echo chamber
it's it's tough it is harder and harder
as that you know obviously I focus more
now on on doing this show meaning the
the direct to camera talking to you
sharing the news with you than I do on
the interviews we're doing one or two
interviews a week but part of the reason
was because it also became basically
impossible
to find people that would sit down with
me that disagreed with me on things uh
that that were that had legitimate
backgrounds or something like I can find
some random hater on YouTube that would
love to come on here and yell at me
um but because the left has become so
crazy and because if you sit down with
someone who doesn't agree with us on
this then you are like them too it
became harder and harder to do that so I
will always always look for those other
avenues to find new people in this thing
and I can just tell you guys after
touring on this last book and and
everything I've done and the amount of
email I get I mean the amount of people
who disagree on a whole bunch of things
and are still here because we love
America we love freedom we don't want to
give this thing away and we want to stop
what is the greatest threat which is
this Confluence of wokism and the
uniparty and the globalists and all
these things it's like
I'll take that bet I'll take that bet
that we can do it I really will guys
it's me Monday over at the locals
Community here's what I put up 2021 if
anyone refuses the coveted shot they
should be fired put in camps have their
kids taken be denied Medical Care and
left to die 2022 we were all misinformed
let's just forgive each other and forget
about it we'll find out what 2023 brings
on that but a couple hundred people
already have put in some comments so
please jump in and do that and now if
you'd like to join us for the post game
show lots of people have been joining we
take some questions some comments and a
bunch more you can join us in about 30
seconds at reubenreport.locals.com and
my full interview with Dr Robert Malone
you guys know Malone he is the doctor
that owns more mRNA patents than anybody
basically invented mRNA technology and
has become probably the premier voice in
warning against these vaccines think
about that part that full interview is
up right now so you can check that out
we will be back with the post game show
momentarily have a great Monday
everybody
join us tonight is a father named Doug
he wrote Jill my wife a letter anybody
who doubts it
I'll give you a copy
[Music]
it's such a pain sack should have never
happened
it is not fair
[Music]
foreign